nice capital welcome to Michelle
Williams it's a real change for me to
have my own story to tell and not
somebody else's so thank you speaker
Pelosi for the invitation to join you
this afternoon and to observe this
important day equal pay day I'm grateful
to you and to congresswoman DeLauro and
to all of the Democratic women of
Congress who have been steadfast in your
pursuit of securing equal rights for
women and for all people in our country
so I'm here to tell you my story and
it's the kind of story that I would
normally resist the morality tale with a
happy ending or maybe I should call it a
happy beginning because that's really
why I'm here
there won't be satisfaction for me until
I can exhaust my efforts ensuring that
all women experienced the elevation of
their self-worth and it's connection to
the elevation in their market worth that
I have become so fortunate to finally
know after 25 years in my chosen
profession in late 2017 the news broke
that I'd been paid less than $1,000
compared to the 1.5 million dollars
that my male counterpart had received
for the exact same amount of work and
guess what no one cared this came as no
surprise to me it simply reinforced my
life learned belief that equality was
not an inalienable right and that women
would always be working just as hard for
less money while shouldering more
responsibility in their homes and if it
was like this for me a white woman in a
glamorized industry how were my sisters
suffering across their professions
when the news passed as quickly as it
had broken i sat paralyzed in feelings
of futility I've been a working actress
since the age of 12 and I've taken every
challenge as an opportunity I've been
accredited within my industry at the
highest levels and that still did not
translate into equal and fair
compensation
months passed and the actress jessica
chastain with whom i had in fact once
played sisters asked my permission to
take my story to her twitter she
recognized three things first injustice
second timing it was a different moment
there is a new clearing in the air that
thanks to the mounting me to movement
and the work of Toronto Burke and the
courage of so many women coming forward
to tell their stories and third was her
platform in her power
Jessica's audience was much wider than
mine and she wasn't afraid to pick up a
megaphone and be heard and heard she was
there was an uproar and a public shaming
within my industry that resulted in a 2
million dollar donation to the times of
Legal Defense Fund a group of fellow
actresses and I invited activists as our
dates to the 2018 Golden Globes where I
was a nominee and rather than talk about
our dresses we voiced solidarity for the
oppressed and violated women in our
industry and across all industries we
were all a part of the newly forming
times of organization and seeking to
roll out change in our industry as a
rallying cry for others when I went back
to work after these events I could tell
that my workplace was shifting rather
than being grasped too tightly and
hugged for too long as a morning
greeting my hand was shaken and I was
looked squarely in the eye and I was
welcomed to my Monday morning I realized
this is actually what it feels like to
be on the inside to be one of the boys
in this space respect and safety are out
in the open they are not just found in
the shadows and the corners and on the
job I just completed two weeks ago let
me tell you something I was paid equally
with my male co-star
and now we're at the heart of why I
traveled here to talk to you the
firsthand experience that I hope
decision-makers can hear from this
platform that I've been given when a
person or a group of people acknowledge
your worth you seek to meet that worth
because they see you as you want to be
seen which is as of value and when you
feel you are valued you express your
value and where does that value go it
goes to your work it goes to your fellow
colleagues it goes to your employer it
benefits your entire organization it
strengthens the parts that advance the
whole this is the kind of human math
that it only takes a heart to add up
imagine a workplace where women don't
have to spend extra or any energy
fighting for fair pay or defending their
rights but can instead focus that energy
on the fullest expression of the task at
hand and enjoy both the pride that
brings and the product of that pride
which is fair and equal compensation for
every woman the ball is now in the
Senate's Court women families in our
country will win if members of the US
Senate
take the decisive action that is
required to pass the Paycheck Fairness
Act this is the next critical moment
please don't let it pass us by
[Applause]